DAVID LEE: One by one we shine.
But together we flourish.
We Flourish
celebrates the stories
of Asian and Asian
American Princeton alumni,
while also highlighting the
power of coming together
as a community.
Hello, I'm David Lee, Provost
of Princeton University.
The Asian community has
a longstanding history
at Princeton, beginning with
Hikoichi Orita from Japan,
who graduated in 1876.
There are so many individual
stories from all regions.
By sharing our
Princeton experiences,
we further strengthen
our Princeton ties.
Today, Asian and Asian
American students
make up nearly a quarter
of the student body.
With family roots that
reach all across Asia,
our students pursue
their passions
in areas such as literature,
sciences, music, and the arts.
Princeton is, and should
be, a place where students
can discover and celebrate the
richness of diverse cultures,
including their own.
YOUNGSUK Y.S. CHI: I grew
up all over the world.
SPEAKER 1: From Hong
Kong originally, but I
moved to Sydney some 30 years--
FRANKLIN ODO: So I
grew up in Honolulu.
I was born there in 1939.
SPEAKER 2: Hanoi.
PAULA CHOW: I'm from
Shanghai, China.
REGINA LEE: So I'm
Chinese American.
On my mother's side
of the family--
RAJ VINNAKOTA: I was actually
born in Lausanne, Switzerland.
CAILIN HONG: Second
generation born here.
CHRIS LOH: I was born in Taiwan.
EVAN KRATZER: I'm
personally half Japanese
and half a variety of
Western European countries
mixed together.
KANWAL MATHARU: Born and
raised in New Orleans.
I'm a Cajun baby.
RISHI JAITLY: I
grew up in New York.
SPEAKER 3: China and Hong Kong.
SPEAKER 4: I grew up thinking
I was Italian American.
SPEAKER 5: From the Philippines.
EVA LERNER-LAM: One
day it was November.
It was dusk and it was snowing.
And we were waiting to make
a right onto Nassau Street.
FRANKLIN ODO: The alternative
to working on the farm
was to find a way to
justify to your parents
ways you could
avoid being there.
So I did Boy Scouts, 4H Club.
I played every
sport I could find.
EVA LERNER-LAM: I looked up
there, and my mom was driving.
And I said, Mom, what's that?
And she said, that's
Princeton University.
And I said, wow.
I want to go there.
FRANKLIN ODO: I didn't know at
the time, and nobody told me,
this was the way
you craft a resume
to get invited to join an Ivy.
EVA LERNER-LAM: And my
mom pulled the car over
to the side.
She put it in park.
She looked at me and she
said, Eva, in this world
not everything is fair.
You'll never be able
to go to Princeton
because Princeton
doesn't take girls.
And I looked back in the
window and I looked at my mom,
and I said, I'll
figure out a way.
I have to go there.
FRANKLIN ODO: It
was a great honor.
And it made me a local hero.
EVA LERNER-LAM: And then nine
years later, provost Bill Bowen
somehow managed to get our fine
university to be coeducational.
And I was able to apply,
and I got in, and I came.
YOUNGSUK Y.S. CHI: I was
a foreign student when
I came to Princeton from Korea.
And so my identity was
really as a foreigner first.
RAJ VINNAKOTA: So I had
what one would consider
to be a fairly stereotypical
Asian family upbringing
when it came to education.
YOUNGSUK Y.S. CHI: My
habits, my way of thinking,
my expectations were shaped by
where I came from, by my mother
and father and my relatives.
RAJ VINNAKOTA:
Our parents pushed
us to make sure that we
did as much as possible
in as many ways as possible.
REGINA LEE: We
were few in number.
I think my class had about 50
Asian/Asian American students.
TIMOTHY WU: I was a foreign
Asian student coming
from Singapore, and I spent my
first couple weeks on campus
walking around going,
what's lacrosse?
What's an a cappella
singing group?
YOUNGSUK Y.S. CHI: We were
also not very much understood
by the rest, because they
didn't come to Princeton already
having been exposed to
the variety of students
that Princeton was
trying to educate.
TEDDY ZHOU: I was the
first undergraduate
from China, mainland
China, to say, since 1949.
Princeton admission was my
ticket to the free world.
So I'm very, very grateful.
MARY YEE: My own
socioeconomic background
is very different
from the mainstream
Princetonian at that time.
DANILO JOA: At the time, we feel
like maybe fish out of water.
Maybe we didn't belong.
Maybe was a big fluke.
But I got in.
And I'm very glad to see
the Princeton of today
is much more diverse and open
to students of all colors
and creeds.
SANJEEV KULKARNI:
And I think diversity
is an important part of the
university mission, that
is, the teaching and research
mission to really fully carry
that mission out.
I think we have to be educating
a diverse group of students
at both the undergraduate
and graduate level.
Second, diversity
actually impacts
the quality of the research
and teaching that we do.
I think by having a different
diverse set of students,
faculty, staff, we get the
best ideas out on the table
make the most progress
in those realms.
But third, it actually
impacts the quality
of the experience, the
educational experience of all
the students that are here
by giving them an opportunity
to experience the other.
CAILIN HONG: We really see a
very multicultural, wide range
of individuals represented
here at Princeton.
And it's really great to be able
to see that mixing pot here.
KANWAL MATHARU: To be
able to say yes, there
are a lot of Asian students.
Yes, there are communities here.
Yes, we're building, we're
growing, we're moving,
we're shaping, we're
integrated into the fabric
of the university.
I think that is useful.
GARY PAI: I feel that if
you follow your passions,
do what you are really
strong and enjoy doing,
you will end up in a
place and in a career
that you'll find far more
fulfilling than what you
thought you were going to do.
RAJ VINNAKOTA: I'm a huge
believer in a liberal arts
education.
I didn't realize
it at that time,
but even more so
today, what you need
is a grounding in
how to think, in how
to approach problems, in
how to look at history
and apply it to the present.
Cary LIU: It turns
out that Princeton
has one of the
strongest collections
of Chinese art in the nation.
And one of the things
about Princeton's education
in the graduate program, and
even in the undergraduate,
is that the students are brought
in to work with the collection.
EUNJEONG CHI: I chose
art history as my major.
And the courses that
mattered to me the most
were definitely the ones that
I took with my eventual thesis
advisor.
And he focused on Chinese
art and architecture.
SOOJEONG CHI: I actually think
my Chinese language courses
were my favorite classes,
just because they're
really-- I know.
You're laughing because I
probably complained about it
all the time.
At the time, it's so
rigorous that you're
kind of just blinded by it.
It's so much work.
it's good, because you're
learning anything more quickly
than everybody else.
But they're small,
really focused classes.
CHRIS LOH: I felt very
comfortable interacting
in the mainstream
community, as well as
in the Asian American community.
YOUNGSUK Y.S. CHI: I
felt very much supported
by the university.
We had the Office of
International Students,
and the unforgettable
Paula Chow.
I mean, she was our
mother to all of us.
PAULA CHOW: Welcome back.
We are in Beijing,
China, where Gregory
is giving a few lectures.
We want to send you our
love and our best wishes
for your continuous success.
GREGORY CHOW: Today
I wouldn't be here
if I weren't the
husband of Paula Chow.
PAULA CHOW: That is
absolutely not true.
But I do want to say one thing.
Because of my work with
the University League,
I got involved
with Louise Sayen,
and then we called ourselves
the International Center.
And then it became something
a little bit well-known,
and then slowly well-known
until four years later.
We were invited to move into--
GREGORY CHOW: Murray-Dodge?
PAULA CHOW: To
Murray-Dodge, yes.
RISHI JAITLY: For me,
Princeton was a place
to discover my heritage.
I candidly, growing up,
coming into Princeton,
didn't really connect
with my Asian heritage.
I felt very American.
And I said, you know, I ought
to be intentional about this.
So I joined a South
Asian theater group.
I joined Naacho, the
Indian dance group,
which I think is still around.
And then I created and
produced some of my own events.
So for me, my
journey at Princeton
was coming in very unaware
of, really, my background.
And I left quite aware.
NICHOLAS WU: Personally, I
consider the United States
to be my home country.
I mean, I was born,
I was raised here.
I consider myself
to be American.
But it was definitely very
good to have this experience,
to go back and explore the
culture and the language
of my ancestors.
ELLA CHENG: Luckily, Princeton
has given me, actually,
more opportunities
than even my own family
to explore my Chinese side and
my Asian American side because
of the clubs here
and the people here,
but also because I was able to
attend programs like Princeton
at Beijing, where I went back
to China for the first time,
actually, in my life, and was
able to learn the language
and really immerse myself
in the culture there
in a different way.
So yeah, it's been
a great place for me
to grow my identity as well.
APRIL CHOU: Over the
years, one of the topics
that I got very
involved with was
that of Asian American studies.
FRANKLIN ODO: So
I taught a seminar
on Asian American
History Spring of 1995.
There were 20 kids in the class.
APRIL CHOU: I
remember, at the time,
doing a fair bit
of research just
to understand the history
and context of these issues
at that time.
It included admissions,
included ethnic studies,
it included faculty hiring.
FRANKLIN ODO: As we got
towards the end of the semester
and we were studying what
we called the Asian American
Movement, beginning where I
had participated in 1969, 1970,
in sit-ins, demonstrations,
hunger strikes, and so on.
APRIL CHOU: Ultimately,
after several years of,
I think, working through
the appropriate channels
and having a lot
of conversations,
we ultimately decided
to do a sit-in, in part
in peaceful protest,
but to really
elevate the level of
attention and commitment
around these issues.
FRANKLIN ODO: The students
were extremely principled.
They never let on that
they were planning this,
because they must
have been planning it
in the course of the semester.
APRIL CHOU: This is
actually inside the sit-in.
We sang a lot of
hymns, a lot of hymns
from the Civil Rights movement.
FRANKLIN ODO: And you
know, some of them
were first generation
college students,
and they had a lot to lose,
because if the University
had applied sanctions, including
expulsion, that was insane.
APRIL CHOU: This is me the
night after we came out.
This was, I think, a moment of
great celebration and relief
that our voices had been
heard, and that there
were some changes to come.
I view it all as a
very long-term path,
and that we're really trying
to have an impact on the things
that are not just for when
we're students or alums here,
but for the generations to come.
SHERYL WUDUNN: I think
this is really important,
this conference,
because it's not
to say that we need to
have a solidarity movement.
It's really just that we want
to be-- we feel that we really
have comrades, friends that we
can feel comfortable sharing
experiences with, especially
as they relate to Princeton.
I think this conference
is very important
to instill that sense of
spirit among all of us.
Now I'm a trustee, one
of seven Asian or Asian
American trustees, out
of about 40 trustees.
That's a really large minority.
That's a significant presence.
And it makes me really proud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
APRIL CHOU: One
of the things that
has been such a blessing
about being involved with A4P
is really getting to know
and work with Princetonians
across different generations
that I otherwise, I think,
may not have had an
opportunity to meet.
And I really feel
like today we're
standing on the shoulders
of several giants
who were each trailblazers
in their own right.
And in particular, I
had the great privilege
of working with Kelly Kuwayama,
who was Class of 1940.
And as you can imagine, his
experiences here at Princeton
were very different from
those that I experienced,
and those that students today
are probably experiencing.
He had a way of listening
and taking things in.
But when he spoke,
people really listened.
I also really wanted to honor
Sue-Jean Lee Suettinger, who
was Class of '70.
She really was such a
powerful and quiet leader.
And yet this conference,
We Flourish, was her dream.
The other person I
really wanted to speak of
is Dora Lee, who
was Class of '76.
She was such a believer in
bringing people back together,
and was one of these people that
held her orange and black so
closely.
So I really wanted to
honor the three of them,
and to acknowledge
that I think many of us
wouldn't be here
at this conference,
or working together, had it not
been for their contributions
and their leadership.
CHRISTOPHER EISGRUBER:
What a pleasure
it is to welcome
Princeton's Asian and Asian
American alumni to the
We Flourish Conference.
These alumni conferences have
become a wonderful vehicle
for this university to reach
out and embrace its alumni
community, and to
bring back groups that
are important to
this university,
and allow you to
interact with the campus,
with your classmates, and
with our current students.
We're delighted to have you
here for this conference,
and I look forward to
interacting with all of you
I hope you have
a wonderful time.